intermat 1 voici le journal de gérard
courchelle situation insurrectionnelle
en roumanie des tirs toute la nuit dans
les rues de bucarest plusieurs milliers
de jeunes gens tiennent toujours le
centre ville d'autres cités du pays se
soulève contre la dictature la
répression d'hier malgré les démentis
officiels auraient fait des dizaines de
morts et de blessés dans la capitale
à timisoara en dépit de l'état de siège
la moitié de la population a défilé pour
réclamer le départ du clan c'est aussi
ce que le pouvoir politique et militaire
romain serait en pleine désintégration
le ministère hongrois de la défense
parle d'une situation insaisissable la
surveillance téléphonique se relâche
pour la première fois depuis le début
des troubles
nous entendrons le témoignage direct
d'une habitante de bucarest
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
se réunit dans la journée l'attitude
soviétique qui sera déterminante tout le
monde a déjà remarqué le rôle moteur de
la chance tu as dans la propagation des
nouvelles venues de roumanie au panama
noriega est toujours introuvable les
américains commencent à redouter
l'enlisement de leur force
d'intervention unanimité de tous les
groupes de l'opposition à une voix près
pour voter la motion de censure à
l'assemblée
265 voix il en fallait 289 pour
renverser le gouvernement
un week end de trois jours pour les
fêtes de noël beaucoup de monde sur les
routes dans les gares et les aéroports
le point dans ce journal
quel prix le peuple roumain devra-t-il
payer pour sa liberté combien de vies
humaines le régime sait où ces secousses
sacrifiera-t-il encore pour tenter de se
maintenir dans tous les autres pays de
l'est le changement s'est fait sans
violences ou presque mais en roumanie ce
n'est pas un parti et un gouvernement
vermoulu qu'il s'agit d'abattre c'est
une famille tout un clan arrivée au
pouvoir de toutes ses forces
hier après midi à bucarest le scénario
de timisoara s'est reproduit la milice
de seo sea skua ouvert le feu sur la
foule
il y a des morts et des blessés
impossible d'en évaluer le nombre toute
la nuit plusieurs milliers d'étudiants
ont continué à occuper le centre de la
capitale malgré les interventions des
chars et des hélicoptères qui ont fait
de nouvelles victimes
tout à l'heure nicolas poincaré a réussi
à joindre une habitante de bucarest
elle le dit les contestataires ne lâche
pas prise
mce et dans la classe qu'on appelle un
républicain d'iowa le palais qui sont
mandela va entourer de véhicules
militaires de batiscan longtemps il
paraît que on entend des rafales et s'il
n'entend que l'hélicoptère qui
certainement survole la laïcité tout est
maintenant les étudiants étaient très
bien ils ont envoyé des émissaires
ils ont fait venir les ouvrir il paraît
que les ouvriers de deux très grandes
usines de karel appel aux essais en vol
un toit ou et l'autre usine de machines
lourdes où se sont aussi arrivés dans le
centre ils se sont massés du côté de
l'hôtel intercontinental équipes
arrivent là aussi cela les trotteurs
prête à intervenir
certainement que rien ne s'est calmée
absolument rien qu'elle n'y a pas de
dialogue
quelle est l'ambiance dans du castro
elle est très intense et vu que folle
les les autobus et matin 5h les gens
autour de vous comment ils réagissent à
tous elles ont l'impression que tout est
en train de basculer
ah oui ah oui tout le monde est plein
d'espoir tout le monde est plein
d'espoir tout le monde et c'est qu'enfin
enfin il un lien avec toute la clique
certainement tellement clients sont
comme toujours des amplis n'y a ni mais
en général tout le monde tout le monde
n'était que ça d'ailleurs d'être
tellement les div
les désirs de tout le monde sait que la
manifestation à nu
énormément l'adhérence bras curial
énormément désormais guy tellement plus
de calme règne est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que d'un seul coup les gens
n'ont plus peur
là on a beaucoup moins peur qu
auparavant
c'est tout le pays qui se taisent et
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre mot voilà
c'était le témoignage d'une roumaine de
bucarest recueillis aux premières heures
de la matinée par nicolas poincaré de
france info cette dame vient de nous
expliquer que les roumains aujourd'hui
n'ont plus peur
il y a quelques jours une telle
conversation au téléphone était presque
impossible impossible parce que les
roumains n'osais pas à s'exprimer
impossible parce que les communications
téléphoniques avec la roumanie ne
passait pas ce relâchement de la
surveillance traduit peut-être ce que le
ministère hongrois de la défense
aplatir soir la désintégration du
pouvoir politique et militaire romain le
régime ceausescu est aux abois
d'autant qu'il n'y a pas que bucarest
d'autres villes se soulève à timisoara
où est née la révolte la semaine
dernière cent cinquante mille personnes
sont descendues dans la rue hier les
forces de sécurité ne sont pas
intervenues un comité pour le socialisme
et la démocratie s'est constitué dans la
ville tout est paralysé par une grève
générale
les étudiants de bucarest appelle
d'ailleurs tous les roumains à rejoindre
ce mouvement de grève pour obtenir le
départ de ces os est ce qu à l'heure
qu'il est il est toujours difficile
sinon impossible d'entrer en roumanie
dominique de l'ars oi à l'envoyé spécial
de france inter partis avec une mission
de médecins sans frontières est bloqué
sur la frontière hongroise